*bruit d'hélicotère* Plan hélico sur Paris
*bruit d'hélicoptère* Cartons titre à méga explosions
*bruit d'explosion* Vous n'avez pas ri depuis longtemps ! *bruit d'explosion*
Peut-être même que vous n'avez jamais ri !
*bruit d'explosion* Ils arrivent sur votre internet
*gros bruit d'explosion* Ça se calme un petit peu comme ça. Puis on voit une silhouette, deux silhouettes, trois silhouettes, quatre petites silhouettes comme ça !
Il y a des petits chants grégoriens qui montent.
*chantonne*
*bruit d'explosion* Vincent Tirell ! *bruit d’explosion* Raphaël Descraques ! *bruit d'explosion* Flober !*gros bruit d'explosion* Julien Josselin !
*bruit bizarre* Onde de choc. *bruit bizarre*
Suricate !
Ouais c'est ... c'est quoi euh ... Suricate ?
Ah bah c'est nous quoi, enfin c'est ... c'est l'équipe ... c'est Suricate.
Et euh ... Pourquoi euh ... Pour... Pourquoi les Surciates ?
Ah non attention pas LES Suricates, juste Suricate.
Ouais, et pourquoi Suricate ? Genre.. je vois pas bien le rapport avec nous, je ...
*bruit*
Suricate !